from Kardashians dancing to fiancee
singing Diana Ross the 75th birthday
celebration was the place to be on
Tuesday night I just want to know where
our invitations were lost in the mill
probably Diana first kicked off her big
bday more than a month ago singing happy
birthday to herself backstage at the
Grammys
she wrapped things up on Tuesday March
26 her actual birthday with two epic
parties back-to-back first a
star-studded soiree at the Warwick
followed by a midnight concert at the
iconic Hollywood Palladium
[Music]
yep and I witnessed lzt Kourtney and
Khloe Kardashian we're pulled on stage
to dance for a few minutes to take me
higher before Diana pulled their mom
Kris Jenner and her kids Tracee Ellis
Ross and Evan Ross to ease on down the
road let's just point out the fact that
the Kardashians were actual fangirls in
the pit we French Montana
Andy Dick Allen my favorite thing is
seeing celebrities fangirl over other
celebrity I know it makes them feel more
real right and then there was also
Khloe's Diana Ross inspired hair did we
like it Kate I liked it because if
you're ever gonna do hair like that it
has to be to a party celebrating Diana
Ross and I think she nailed it yeah
there were definitely some mixed
reactions online but let's get back to
Queen Diana Ross who belted out all the
classics that we love
[Applause]
dianna performed hit after hit at her
party including a duet with robin thicke
for endless love
[Music]
and after Diana made an outfit change
into a turquoise dress a Stevie Wonder
came out to sing his own version of
happy birthday
I mean legends singing to legend I know
[Applause]
[Music]
just like Diana's outfit changes kept
coming five to be exact so did the stars
serenading her in song before they cut
the cake okay
and then at Diana's after-party Beyonce
also grabbed the mic to sing can you
imagine this sounds like your dream
happening I know one legend performance
for another legend it just kept
happening all night but another
highlight from the evening Diddy bopping
out to perform his song a sample from
Diana's collection I'm coming out
[Music]
huh but Diddy's duties didn't stop there
he was a proud dad from the sidelines as
his twin daughters Delilah and Jesse
James gave us old-school supreme vibes
did he eventually jumped in with his
girls like a true dance dad one thing we
were surprised to see at the concert
Diana Ross showing off her rapping chops
with DJ Khaled
[Music]
[Applause]
Leonardo DiCaprio was also in the
building seemingly trying to remain
low-key in a black hoodie our insider
says Diana pulled the reluctant actor on
stage with his mom though to end the
concert there's no hiding from Miss
Diana Ross no there is it now that
seemed like the party to be at Diana
Ross is obviously a legend so it's only
right that she celebrate her bday like a
queen so we want to know from you guys
what was your favorite highlight from
inside the bash be sure to let us know
and of course subscribe to ET for more
exclusive news until next time I'm Katie
Krauss and I'm Courtney terzano bye for
now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]